it's rare for a president to show up to
the un general assembly and attack
another world leader directly but that's
exactly what joe biden decided to do
let us speak plainly
a permanent member of the united nations
security council invaded its neighbor
attempted to erase the sovereign state
from the map
russia has shamelessly violated the core
tenants of the united nations charter
his comments coming just hours after
vladimir putin announced the biggest
military mobilization in russia since
world war ii an announcement which
warned of a nuclear response to threats
to russia
this world should see these outrageous
acts for what they are
putin claims he had to act
because russia was threatened
but no one threatened russia
and no one
other than russia
sought
conflict
biden's address set the scene for
perhaps the most eagerly anticipated
speech of this general assembly from
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky it
was pre-recorded and that had to be
approved by a separate vote president
zielinski demanded the un itself do more
to punish russia for what he called its
aggression reject the right to vote
deprive delegation rights remove the
right of veto
if it is a member of the u.n security
council
in order to punish the aggressor within
the institutions zolensky said the
russian mobilization was a sign it was
not serious about peace as he laid out
his five-point plan to end the war what
is true then
the military mobilization
in russia is true
shem referendums are also true
russia wants war it's true but russia
will not be able to stop the cause of
history
mankind and the international law are
stronger than one terrorist state
the russian delegation listened to the
speech but sat unmoved at the end
as the ukrainian president received a
lengthy standing ovation
not once in his 25-minute speech did
president zelinski mention vladimir
putin's name
but he believes ukraine can win the war
with increased international support
both here at the united nations
and in ukraine itself
alan fisher al jazeera at the un in new
york